go into out so the vulnerability of
opening your mouth and consuming a
liquid or water or food
start there filter your water that's
affecting
98 of many parts of the country in pfos
and microplastics so filter your water
minimize Ultra processed food because
everything from heavy metals and pfos
and and other bisphenols are showing up
also in that lotions that are staying on
your body these things you should be
looking for natural
products that are clean and healthy for
your skin and then you know work your
way out work your way out to your
clothing and be more responsible like
that work your way out to your your home
what kind of cleaning products you don't
have to be perfect but you're just
moving forward to clean up your
environment so that you can have the
best life ever